vai vai io raccolgo i soldi è bellissimo
pietro io farei solo presto tutto
ragazzi miei questo ve lo devo spiegare
primo episodio di sea of thieves che ho
fatto l'ho fatto da solo dove avevo la
barca singola e sono affondato il
secondo episodio l'ho fatto in coppia
con pietro entra il terzo episodio
questo che state vedendo siamo in
quattro sulla nave quindi abbiamo la
nave più grande di tutte e siamo io
dietro storm degli illuminati e novak è
un nostro amico e abbiamo deciso di fare
una missione ovviamente il gioco di da
una mappa con delle scritte che bisogna
decifrare e dobbiamo raggiungere un
isola nascosta e dentro quest'isola c'è
un tesoro nascosto
buona visione ragazzi il cappelluto
maroni cura dei maroon ying
ok la grandeur van deer valley ma non
capisco neanche la metà di quello che ci
siano un rooster un coraggio fair
tu sei un mostro non resti un mostro
andiamo in puglia e veloce a questa che
fai adesso medicino stiamo andando ad
app l'inter valley tebella food valley
questa è l'isola che tiene il tesoro
sicuro definito binario c'è scritto per
valley found on the valley e beh
effettivamente se un po perspicace no
non c'era arrivato subito che potrà
essere la plunder valle dalla scritta
blunder valle ragazzi è un attimo che
chi è che al timone nessuno pietro
meglio che non c'era nessuno qualcuno lo
tolga dovremmo andare verso pericolo le
coordinate tra le dice che mi sembra che
nord est paga io vi dico cosa vedo cosa
verifica a destra [ __ ] a sinistra niente
quelle fatica anche mal timone
ma da una nuova gira a destra no no ma
la ragazza ha avuto il relitto a
sinistra vogliamo controllare ma è il
momento di sganciare l'ancora non
lasciarla lì a tre vai 11 e mezzo due
via al mezzo
lei ha sì calcio adesso adesso altri
piani
sì ma una bellissima bene la prendi più
slancio dalla dalla dalla torre ragazzi
sbagliato quindi non è infinito giusto
che io sto col cannocchiale sott'acqua e
utilizzati dentro bene come si entra
verrà da ali grazie pietro regole quando
voi se gli squali occhio occhio occhio
questa suonando perché sono anche
sott'acqua come non è pubblico non c'era
nulla abbiamo ne aveva va bene perfetto
bel bello perché è stato bello ma vuoi
un bello escluso estreme quali mangiate
pietro che è più grasso dopo via via via
via quale e hanno fatto male e poi via
via tutti sono mia l'angolo aver ancora
subito non aspettate gli altri
aspettativa tranchida ci metto norma
potrebbe morire guarda non me ne frega
niente dovete line cambiamo di vita uno
di vita
vai aspetta ragazzi però io credo che
ognuno debba avere un proprio ruolo in
questa nave io timo no io suono a io
volevo suonare
ok ma se premies macrico centro per
rinchiuderlo raga dovremo andare a
sinistra
eccola qua non tirare e qui si arriva in
quest'isola sensi come diceva micigliano
vicin a noce si sta sparando spiegato
parlando ci ha sparato la soprano
candoni occhio ragazzi passare un'ora
gaio aiuto maron
già mancati su scarsi no cioè sì però
sono sicuro mi sono assicurato ricarica
c'è un entrata vai giù un muro
ieri durante la prima che cada e vabbè
dai via via via via va bene anche così
vai vai ecco fare un'edizione del 13
sparato storica mi sono ripresa la
monica mi che fanno discutere
ci siamo di questi sparava lega c'è uno
scheletro lavori sparava realtà di
sparare sentenze list ieri e tirocini ok
lori dietro la donna marca non l'ho
visto mai
grazie store ricordiamo come che ci sono
perché la cirrosi di un acqua dentro c'è
qualcosa oggi pone tra alterne ma allora
dicevo io e te e basta e va bene
esattamente così parmalat il tutto
mentre cerca che diceva che lo dice a
bloomberg valle mustér trova la pietra
del guardiano del kenya un pass
secondo me era in via arapietra del work
lori che ho perso
sono dietro di te sei borghese di buona
donna aspetta
secondo me qui la pietra del destino del
drago di qualche parte nel descrivere
the dragon ball è qua siamo in una
caverna qualsiasi norma dobbiamo trovare
un canyon è davvero il segno non è un
canyon qua eco giova cascata produce
ancora mangiando a dire ecco la fare una
scatola alla prorompente ma siamo usciti
ma dobbiamo andare al passaggio dei
canyon a questa l'accademia di parole
melo prova perfetta cdc altro regalo poi
c'è allora aspettavamo
leggere abbiamo non aver fermato e kata
in purissimo stato il ci sono delle luci
che cosa sta facendo e sarà chi è che ha
sparato colpi di avvertimento vengono
qua ci fanno canale piccola si si non
vale niente
vabbè allora find the guardian of canyon
trova il guardiano del passaggio del
canyon kick ass il guardiano nel
passaggio che sarà uno con la barbara un
mostro dov'è la pietra
eccolo eccole qua ma perche la ma siamo
su 276 d'ora non è vero che siamo sì è
lui è lui è lui per forza c'è uno stato
di un qualcosa sotto dove siamo usciti
la mappa in teoria trivieri l'evento
esatto funziona funziona bisogno di
tutto verde mamma mia ragazza e farlo
quindi mica se non ci fossi io se non ci
fossi io allora allora e lo scarabeo
nascosto legge l'angolo del nord est
beach prova a scheletri porca vacca
adesso questo leggendo questo e lo
scarabeo nascosto alla cima del
dalla di spiaggia di nord est sei pronto
a rompere la terra no per ora un
telepass nord est la spiaggia della
busso robbie onore scarabeo the kids are
you ready to black ap devi fare i passi
e scavare per terra accusato nord est
questa all'angolo andare all'angolo
all'angolo da nord est flash ancora e
questo no ok mi vedono trovino scarabeo
maledetto per cortesia scarabeo l'angolo
è questo allora l'angolo della nord est
bici deve essere questo quindi dovrebbe
esserci un una scarpa vecchia trona
scarabeo e mezzo sta roba
un caso veramente tutto nuova eccola il
colosso vengo qua e sul muro a
maledizione mamma mia ragazza mi piace
farlo deve farlo che sei qui sul muro
vieni ti all'angolo buone l'angolo dei
passi este by nord est est nord est
tieni premuto sinistra con la bussola
perché per i passi ne vengo a prendere
est nordest di vite la spiaggia o 2 3 4
5 6 dovrebbe essere qua in teoria
c'è slop peccato subito a regalo jack
farlo number one conoscono vivibile
credibile madonna sherlock e chi regala
ok ok ai pick up navara per lascia già
tutto questo ci voleva così rachel è
però nella vittoria è esatto
vai vai storm e fa il palestrato di
saltare con una casa di almeno 30 40 kg
così allegramente e madre quanto
sperienza scheletro pietro ma niente del
quotidiano che ci vorrei gli affari non
è la nostra nave credo speriamo mai più
belli studenti odio quando e dove erano
stradale c'è un indovinello per trova
una nave l'idea era qualcuno prendete le
chiavi della nave potrà suonare la marea
scusate veramente non c'è che la nave
non pensi che ridere aveva scusate ma
aveva parcheggiato qui esatto
accademiche non è vero mai
no non ci voglio credere le ganci apre a
fare il giro era qui era qui la gara 4
ma dai
osnato un mistero praticamente la gente
che ci sparavano prima era gente che era
rimasta qui perché altra gente aveva
rubato la nave e quindi è un'isola male
va a cagà ma dai veramente mi chiedo ma
sono veramente è cagato addosso
non è che se la possono rubare veramente
a quanto succedeva dovendo centro
commerciale parcheggi e non sempre lo
stesso le ferite non hanno rubato la
macchina a ci sono degli squali e perché
da scaricare l'app find my ship eravamo
a posto tutti mamma mia ragazzi io sto
notando con le gambe
bellissimo sono curioso di vedere
l'hack è male perché tu porca vacca che
è successo squadra lo sparo pensavo
fossi tu a mordermi le chiappe 9 ma
scusa ecco come ho fatto a salire solo
con te gambe lo vedrai dal video perché
non capisci e quindi ragazzi ho deciso
di interrompere quale episodio perché
non è finito in realtà perché c'è tutto
il ritorno a casa
non vi voglio sbagliare niente ma non è
andata come pensate voi c'è sono
successe cose
nel mentre che tornavamo a casa e ci sta
tutto un altro video per quello che è
successo vi assicuro che forse ancora
meglio di questo nonostante questo sia
uno dei miei preferiti veramente sto
gioco mi fa emozionare come pochissimi
altri quindi non vedo l'ora di far
uscire anche il prossimo episodio che i
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
mi piace anche a vari social comitato
descrizione senso si chiede e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]